I complain a lot when I was young
because I think Bill Gates took odd
opportunities for the Microsoft Steve
Jobs all these guys because without the
ability to influence and persuade your
kids you can't put yourself out there
into the world and be known for what you
really are you go through school and at
least when I did people just focused on
you know academics like achievement
different areas and one of the things
that no one really ever taught me was
like having friends is really valuable
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see exploded
onto the world so to help you on your
journey in today's video we're gonna
showcase two six things that the rich
people do that the poor people don't and
why you're still broke hope you enjoy
alright rule number one is the rich
believe in the law of income
featuring Mark Cuban my best business is
you know solve problems reduce stress
make people's lives easier because
that's what we all look for right in
school you want to get through class you
want to get good grades and you're
looking for the best way to do that when
you start a business you want to make
your customers happy you want to make it
so that they don't think about going
anywhere else but again you always got
to think about your own consumer
experiences what is it about what is it
that you look for and that tends to
guide you would you buy from your own
companies you know and you got to be
honest with yourself because not all
companies are gonna be great but my most
successful companies understand that
rule number two is that the rich focus
on opportunities not obstacles featuring
Jack Ma this world today's of full of
challenges and opportunities 2,000 years
ago full of challenges and opportunities
and I'm sure 2,000 years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there's always it depends on how you
look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people we say there's
no opportunity I complain a lot when I
was young because I think Bill Gates
took odd opportunities for the Microsoft
Steve Jobs all these guys there's no job
there's no great big stuff left for us
but I think opportunity always lies in
the challenges always lies in the
complaints if you can solve the
challenge you have there you will be
successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem of the big opportunity you have
rule number three is the rich associate
with positive successful people
featuring warm button you will move in
the direction of the people that you
associate with so I it's important
associate with people that are better
than yourself and actually the most
important decision many of you may not
all of you will be the spouse you're
choosing and you really you want to
associate with people who are the kind
of person you'd like to be you'll move
in that direction and the most important
person by far in that respect is your
spouse I can't overemphasize how
important that isn't you're right the
friends you have they will form you as
you go through life and make some good
friends keep them for the rest of your
life but have them be people that you
admire as well as Wykeham rule number
four is the rich are willing to promote
themselves and their value featuring
Jordan Belfort Warren Buffett was doing
the speech of Bill Gates about me ten
years ago and he was asked by a college
student what can we do as students to
make ourselves more valuable in the
workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks or investments
you know whatever he would say not what
he says he says go out and take a course
in sales and conservation that he did
Dale Carnegie changed his life there you
go now that point because he took they
said I took Dale Kearney changement
without that you don't he'd be without
that course yeah he'd be the richest
money manager in Omaha Nebraska then no
one ever heard of yeah Annie met his
wife that way but a love
because without the ability to influence
and persuade your cakes you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are
rule number five is the rich are
voracious readers featuring Bill Gates
Elon Musk and Warren Buffett you know I
could always get as many books as I
wanted I could go to the library you
know I had a grandmother who would would
read to us and it was you know it was
thought to be a great thing so early
reading lets you imagine all these
situations and start to think of
yourself you know could I have a run a
business could I ever discover something
in science and I do think some positive
reinforcement hey you you're clever you
can do these things at a young age takes
you a long ways and you know then this
is a great time to be a curious person I
like dog refuse in general
biographies I think are really always
you know really interesting read them
well I think you learn a lot depending
upon you know whose life you're reading
about that there are lots of lessons in
there I read Isaacson's biography of
jobs which I thought was quite
interesting and I actually really liked
I am his biography of Benjamin Franklin
who I would say is certainly one of my
heroes he seemed like a really great guy
basically I sort of was thinking about
this when I went as a kid and trying to
find some meaning in life like what's
the meaning of life you know and I got
quite sort of sad about it actually when
as a teenager and then I read The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
which basically said like the thrill the
rope you know they basically universe is
the answer and you just need to figure
out the questions so I think you know
that that's if I can help kind of figure
out the questions then that I've
considered that to be meaningful
what's your media routine I just read
and read and read I probably read five
to six hours a day I don't read as fast
now as when I was younger but I read
five daily newspapers I read a fair
number of magazines I read 10 Kay's I
read annual reports and I read a lot of
other things too so I I I've always
enjoyed reading I love reading
biographies for example rule number six
the last one before the bonus is the
rich grow bigger than their problems
featuring Dwayne Johnson when I was 24
years old you know I grew up in a world
of wrestling and I loved wrestling my
dad was a wrestler my grandfather was a
wrestler but then I fell in love with
the game of football American football I
played that and I played it till I was
24 years old and when I was 24 years old
I got cut from I got released from my
from the football team I was playing
with in Canada it was a CFL team which
is the Canadian Football League
it's Canada's version of pro football
and I got released it when I got
released I had 7 bucks in my pocket I
literally had seven dollars in my pocket
I had no place to live I had to move
back in with my parents at 24 years old
man and that was a really sobering
experience for me I battled depression
at that time I didn't I had no money
didn't know what I was going to do in my
life so that was that was my version of
Hercules in terms of battling back from
from something big and it also wound up
inspiring me to well get off my ass and
and get to work
now I've got a special bonus rule with
Mark Zuckerberg one of the richest
people alive but before that my question
of the day is I want to know which of
these six rules so far are you lacking
which one is the reason why you're broke
I want to hear from you leave it down
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clip
but the students around me were really
important as well right and both in high
school and in college I mean the people
who started Facebook with me and a lot
of people who are still with me running
the company today are people who I met
when I was at Harvard and some of them
were mighty ups at Harvard right and you
know when the professors were off
writing papers these were the people who
actually taught me and then we hung out
and we had like social bonds and
academic bonds and I just I wouldn't
understate the importance of that and I
mean it's very tied into my whole
philosophy and the product that I spend
my life building Facebook because we
just believe that social bonds are
critical and um in one way that I think
about the the value that Facebook is
filling in the world is that you go
through school and at least when I did
people just focused on you know
academics like achievement different
areas and one of the things that no one
really ever taught me was like having
friends is really valuable no not that I
didn't have friends but but like
although you know the movie yes make it
seem that
but that first girlfriend is for sure I
don't think anyone is like it's not like
okay third-grade we're gonna like
now we're gonna like teach you that like
hanging out with people is a very
important development right and I don't
know I actually think that that is and I
think that's part of the reason why
sometimes people view Facebook as a
waste of time but I actually think it's
this extremely socially valuable utility
and I know that I wouldn't be where I
want where I am today without that
aspect of my life being as developed as
the academic part raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
means that people have passion and not
one drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or living fascinated hey believe nation
if you want to see my all-time favorite
top ten rows of success I have a very
special secret video for you these are
the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details